Si quelqu'un se pose aujourd'hui
en apôtre du cerveau droit,
c'est bien le docteur Jill Bolte Taylor.
Ce qui lui est arrivé
est incroyable.
Un matin de 1996,
elle est victime d'un accident vasculaire
qui noie de sang son hémisphère cérébral gauche.
J'ai été victime
d'un accident vasculaire cérébral,
dans cette région de mon cerveau gauche.
Quand un vaisseau a explosé,
la lésion s'est amplifiée et l'hémorragie
m'a progressivement empêché de marcher,
d'écrire, de me souvenir
du moindre détail de ma vie.
Or, rappelez-vous, le docteur Taylor
est neuro-anatomiste.
Avec une étonnante lucidité,
elle raconte le voyage qui,
depuis la lésion
de son hémisphère gauche,
l'a conduite progressivement à découvrir
les potentialités de son hémisphère droit.
En perdant l'usage de mon hémisphère gauche,
j'ai perdu le souvenir
de tous les détails de ma vie,
c'est-à-dire les informations
relatives à mon travail,
à mes relations,
tout ce qui est constitutif de ma vie
et de mes soucis quotidiens.
Tout d'un coup,
ce stress s'est évanoui.
Il ne me restait plus que la conscience
et la beauté du moment présent.
Et c'était merveilleux.
Tout a changé alors.
Je suis passée dans un espace d'amour,
d'ouverture, de compassion,
de célébration de la vie,
de gratitude pour l'être que je suis.
Et quand les médecins m'ont guéri,
quand ils m'ont redonné l'usage
de mon hémisphère gauche,
quand j'ai pu à nouveau communiquer
et interagir avec les autres,
je l'ai fait en gardant le souvenir de ce
que j'avais découvert dans mon hémisphère droit.
Depuis plusieurs années,
le docteur Bolte Taylor
porte la bonne parole du cerveau droit.
Ce cerveau qu'elle dit programmé
pour l'amour et l'ouverture à l'autre.
Nous ne sommes plus dans la science,
mais dans un prêche quasi religieux
fondé sur la révélation,
que lui a procuré son accident cérébral.
Je fais l'hypothèse que la religion,
est un mode d'accès à l'hémisphère droit
de notre cerveau.
Elle nous permet
d'aller au-delà de nous-mêmes,
de méditer sur les questions essentielles
de notre existence, sur son sens,
de nous arracher aux tumultes
de notre hémisphère gauche,
à cette activité fébrile pour explorer
une zone où nous sommes plus détendus,
plus authentique, plus introspectif.
C'est ce que les gens recherchent
de plus en plus.
Ils sont si contraints
par leur hémisphère gauche,
qu'ils recherchent
cet espace de tranquillité et de paix.
Et c'est ce que nous apporte
l'hémisphère droit.
L'hémisphère droit nous connecte
à la dimension de la spiritualité.
Il nous ouvre à une vision globale
qui abolit les limites.
Et quand les frontières disparaissent,
on est offert à la totalité
de ce qui existe.
On sent la présence de quelque chose
qui est plus grand que soi.
On l'appelle Bouddha, Dieu, Allah.
Peu importe, car cette présence est là,
en nous, dans la conscience
de notre hémisphère droit.